how's it going brahs it looks like
PewDiePie has pewdie died
it's all been documented everything was
going so well
haha this may come as a shock but it was
posted on Facebook by this website if
you click on it it says the most trusted
brand among Hispanics so you know it's
legit
let's read what happened
PewDiePie found dead BBC news I'm just
sick of it and I'm just not getting the
response that I want the most famous
youtuber PewDiePie was found dead
Tuesday afternoon in his apartment in
the UK according to local police some
signs pointed to an accidental overdose
or a suicide although no note was found
police sources said mr. Felix was 25
police sources should know that mr.
Felix was 26 it's mr. shell burg get
your [ __ ] [ __ ] straight he recently
made a video of not having the
connection with his subscribers liking
like he just to do like he just to do
and after the struggle he was on a
subscription for antidepressant pills it
was found dead by his girlfriend marks
episode 9 she hasn't given any official
interview but one of the officers said
she wasn't catatonic state surely the
world is crushed by these news how is
the world possibly going to recover from
this tragic event of news let's find out
rest in peace PewDiePie so young him
name is in real life isn't PewDiePie
that all that's the only response for
those who don't know PewDiePie he's just
an annoying prick who gets millions of
views just yelling at games the [ __ ]
surely there are some nice ones in here
markiplier is better anyway yeah put
that on my gravestone let's read the
comments on the article would have been
so great of he did die would have been
great if you you've learned [ __ ]
basic grammar I am not even [ __ ]
native english-speaking [ __ ] Wow
so he is ghost you're right I have
returned find a flaw in this man he's
alive guess that means I'm flawless
[ __ ] let's look at you bros reaction
surely my own fans will at least be
devastated really [ __ ] Enya how dare
you play any on my funeral what the [ __ ]
is this I'm sorry mine but that's funny
if he's dead
how can he make videos rest in peace
PewDiePie worst YouTube channels ranked
number 1 PewDiePie what really above
Justin Bieber really more than Fred Sam
pepper Matty B are you [ __ ] kidding
me
is this the [ __ ] thanks I get for all
the beautiful videos that I made there
aren't the years
this [ __ ] end well you know what
guess what it was all a prank I'm not
actually dead it was all make up and
guess what I'm gonna keep making videos
y'all got played all right y'all
hope I didn't scare you thank you so
much for watching this video and thank
you so much for watching my videos if I
ever die I want you to know right now
and right here that I love you and
you're beautiful and I appreciate you
loyal but I'm not [ __ ] around Thank
You boys for watching my videos it's
made my life worth living I had to laugh
because I was too sincere stay awesome
rest
oh my god stop this is definitely a boss
damn it